anywhere you go if you've got a
boyfriend you can do what you want as
long as you're [ __ ] respectful I
could go to the carnival there could be
people around me as long as you're
you're doing your own thing and you're
not being I think that's for your man
why can't you I think what you're what
you're not understanding
is your idea of respect in your man
my idea of respecting Your Man
his idea of respecting your man because
when you go out you're representing
yourself that's subjective myself you're
representing yourself because you said
that you go out and he knows that you're
trustworthy you can go out and you can
enjoy yourself your man hasn't got a
problem with it because he's stable with
you you're stable with him that works
for you yeah but
the way he's saying it is that
his woman represents him I'm going to be
honest when he goes out yeah
so are you saying then so let's say you
have a beautiful girlfriend you've been
together for four years you've got okay
let's say this girlfriend you've been
together four years you trust her she's
never given you a reason to ever think
that she'd be doing anything
disrespectful but babe I'm gonna go
Carnival she's dancing she's having a
good time are you gonna think okay what
is she doing why is she dancing like no
she's dancing over man what is she doing
she can't go to Carnival or are you
going to think like my girls at carnival
but I trust her you go with her I'm
gonna go with her because I did go
Carnival over yeah
but why have you ever been kind of
excuse me but have you ever been
Carnival with your man not with my man
have you ever been caught you've never
been kind of of your man but why do you
know what you need to go with what you
need to do is to try having next time
this Carnival have it as like a date day
with your man and you will see the
difference I can understand where I can
understand where he's coming from
because
it's more sexual it's more enjoyable
listen to what I'm saying
go in with your man is more sexual that
is what I said go in as a partner I'm
sure there's lots of people out there
that have been carnival on their own
I've been Carnival I've been in the
floats at the back of the throats I've
been I've been with the with this house
yes I'm a good sound system I don't like
I've done the with salsa band in London
item of another band in Barbados I've
been with I've been in carnival and the
safest place for a single woman to go on
Carnival is in the actual band buy a
costume wear a skin beauty like and buy
a costume other than that if I was gonna
go Carnival I'd go with my man I'd wear
skimpy outfit as possible I would go
with my man and me and my man but if you
had to go Carnival with your woman how
would it be for you not even that let me
tell you how it was for me so let me
tell you about Carnival right because I
did Carnival right so so
see when you go Carnival
um you can walk with your girl by your
side or she could walk a little bit
ahead of you you don't have to you don't
have to walk a hand in hand we don't do
that stuff and it'll be certain times
when you do you know because you have to
yeah because you have to keep you have
to keep together but more times she's
going to be next to your head of you put
your girl two steps ahead of you and see
what happens it's crazy and the only
reason she feels comfortable walking two
steps ahead is because I'm just there I
I didn't realize what it's like for for
a girl to go Carney is actually man and
then when I'm walking through with the
sweet one and then people see you women
respect you more because oh because
they're out there single they're single
ass will know man getting drawn by men
they don't want to chat to you but they
have to deal with it and then men are
out there being hungry trying to chat to
go and you're just there with your girl
catching your one man in your damn
business everyone's seeing you and
they're waiting you know why they're
rating you because they're seeing you
you guys together and there'll be
certain times when your girl's gonna
grab your hand you don't ask to do it
she just grabs it and at that point what
she's saying to you I want you to walk
with me then she'll drop it again and
this is what I'm trying to say to you
like
um go into Carnival you can go by
yourself but but you should go with your
man you know why because that's a whole
next experience that you're about to go
and create and sometimes when you're in
these places these are types of places
where you want to be together you know
what I'm trying to say to you um so
we're not saying you can't go no one's
saying that you can go wherever you want
but there's certain places that you
could certain things are more likely to
happen if Matt had to grab you up on one
it is Carnival I see I see videos on
Tick Tock people getting mad I tried to
chat to try to Wine this is Carnival
this is what people do this is one event
we're basically yeah we were just
talking about we were just we were just
talking about one thing what you're just
talking about so this I've I've never
experienced this this is obviously I've
never been Carnival so I can't speak on
it but I've never experienced this in
I've been to Raves festivals I've been
in large holidays all around the world
I've never experienced what you're
saying I've seen Tick Tock cine tick
tocks yeah I've seen how Barbie is you
know you need to come outside
I've seen all of you like it's packed
together like sardines you're like I've
seen it I've seen how busy it is but
you're you're you are basing a whole
like a relationship an interactional
relationship
what he's saying is that
don't knock it till you tried it this
way
experience is different are you saying
then so if you had a girlfriend let's
say for example you couldn't go to
Carnival she wanted to go to Carney are
you saying to her you're not going no no
no no no no no no I'm not saying but
I'll be quite aware where she goes there
listen I already I already know I'm
gonna look at her no no they might try
to move things no they're not going to
try they're not going to try she's gonna
get about 100 man are you saying to her
you can't go no no I'm not saying that
I'm never saying that you know listen
the only time I'll ever say something
like that is if I generally believe
there's a danger my misses being said
when I say that you should listen to me
because I never say that surely anywhere
she goes
no let's not do that because what you'll
do is what you're doing what you're
doing you're comparing going to the
corner shop in your local area to being
out in the corner place
not just Carney but any event she can go
to yeah you'll miss any event any house
event any Flight Club she's gonna get
hit on see it's not that there's
different levels of risk and what you
guys are doing you guys are in every
level of risk is the same and it's not
like that so what we need to do you've
not been in every single environment no
judge what nobody no but he's been in
carnival listen I've been like the
festival
now first of all actually festivals
festivals and it's totally different
essentially what you're talking about
they don't always right one at a time
what you're talking about the basis if
correct me if I'm wrong here is you're
talking about the trust you have for an
individual when they're at an event
got a better safety hang on up right so
when I when we start going to events in
like 2014 2015 it was full of love good
people Good Vibes and as the years have
gone on events have changed like we are
first of all that has massively changed
now to start attracting the wrong people
yeah has eventually started going too
wrong when people started turning up
wrong crowd started turning up the fire
started changing back in 2014 15 16 17
it was just Good Vibes no trouble no
fights no nothing as the years have gone
on different people different crowds
have started coming here so I don't care
now even going out to clubs that we know
and have been to for years and years and
years and years different people there's
different crowds there's different
people there so of course I'm always
concerned with my girl's safety about
where she's going what club she's going
I don't give I don't care if we're going
okay okay
if I'm if I'm not there I'll make sure
I'll try and know people who are there
who can keep an eye on it
holding it I just cut him down
you just said exactly what I said yeah
you used to go out to this place it used
to be all love Good Vibes now things
have changed now your girl wants to go
to this place that you used to go that
was all like that's all changed now it's
changed last time people got stabbed
last time a girl got satin and she wants
to go yeah and
this is what I'm saying at this point
I'm going to say actually you know what
babe I don't want you to go here now the
reason I don't want you to go has
nothing to be nothing to do other than
the fact that I know someone got stabbed
there it's changed how it used to be
it's not good vibes yeah yeah now
am I wrong for saying that no not at all
bro so then you agree with me what I'm
trying to say is that in this in today's
day and age as well I don't care where
you go
you've got to have your wits about you
no but if you love your girl yeah why
would you put up I'm not going to stop
it listen listen he never said he's
gonna I'm not gonna stop her I can't
stop nobody what's your point let me I
know his point is he's right now he's
right but if you say you're saying you
don't care about your bird but you care
about other people but if you have that
opinion you could when does this stop is
what I'm saying anywhere so even about
that it's like saying it's a one in four
thousand one of the worst ways to travel
is by car you can die get in the Cars
one or four thousand shot one in four
thousand charts you can die in a car
accident yeah right because other people
not because you're driving because of
other people yeah so what does that mean
you don't drive anymore okay but we're
not okay so if you put someone in a car
who is completely sober but you put them
with someone that's completely drunk
yeah that's driving the complete
opposite way that's this is what you're
doing so you're safe but you're putting
someone in an unsafe way in the car no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
you don't no no no no no you tell them
if they're drunk then you say to them if
you go there that person that person's
drunk and I refer you not to go and the
choice is there and then if they get in
that car everyone is sober okay there's
a car coming towards you and there's all
no but listen listen listen we'll use
your analogy right you can't control we
have a cause we use analogy the person's
about to get in the car yeah and they've
got to get in the car with someone
that's drunk they know the person's
drunk and maybe the other people will
knock away hold on a second argument no
because you're trying to say if you're
trying to use the car example so I would
say they use it in a fair example
because I'm saying wait you're not in
control of other drivers yeah the people
in the car you're in control with I
don't want you to drive Mason you're
drunk don't drive what I'm saying is
we're all sober we're in a car there's a
car coming towards you on a motor and
there's a drone the drunk driver
represents the
actuality G right if you're a safe
enough driver and you're prepared enough
you should be able to avoid that job
so as far as I'm concerned
because
you're in a Country Lane
as far as I'm concerned I'll get where
you're coming from because you're not in
control of other people so what you're
trying to say is changing it that if the
car's coming at you and that car's drunk
what are you supposed to do anything can
happen you can go down there right and
what he's trying to say is that if you
know
that there are dangers out there then
all he's going to do is make sure that
his woman is aware of it yeah aware but
exactly that's in every event
he's never said he's going to stop her
from going where she's going all he's
going to say is that the decisions that
she makes of where she's going the
decision that she makes or where she's
going he's going to let her be aware
of what's going on and also another
thing that fees go into Carnival if I'm
going to Carnival if I'm a man and I'm
going to Carnival with girls I'm gonna
I'm gonna dress totally different
because if I'm going out with my man
yeah like he said he's got his woman's
but I can wear whatever I like okay
bucks right because my man's got skimpy
skimpy if I'm going out to Carnival or
somewhere like that I'm gonna make sure
number one I could wear shoes that I can
run in okay okay
smart titties there's nothing hanging
out yeah yeah you know and that I've got
nothing that anybody can grab hold of
I've got like stuff in my pockets a bum
bag or whatever and that's there's a
difference in how you go out to be safe
to be safer you can't stop nothing from
happening yeah but you can give yourself
a damn good chance to prevent it
happening so if you're going out there
and you're this is how we're going to
watch Carnival I will go and I'll stand
up and I would just watch Carnival it'll
go past me yeah
but if I went out there
and I was standing up
and I had on skimpy a bikini yeah that's
what you're saying there is no way I
expect people just to walk past me it
ain't gonna happen not in carnival ain't
gonna happen in carnival it can happen
anywhere but what can I say aren't you
dang as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible